You're about to meet Luis. He runs an
online store that sells railing.
Although he's doing $2.5 million in
revenue, the problem is that 81% of his
customers are coming from a single
source, which is Google Ads. If that
changes or stops working, his business
could be in very serious trouble. So,
first we're going to dive deep into the
business and then we're going to break
down all the tactics that he and you can
use to scale. And at the very end, we're
going to check in with Luis 1 year later
to see if those tactics actually helped
him scale.
>> Hi Alex. My name is Luis Lora, the owner
of Optimum Works, and we are a railing
company and we sell a variety of
railings online. And who we help are
homeowners, contractors, and designers.
And here are some of the examples below
of some of the products we make. Sweet.
How much money do you make? Currently,
we're doing 2.5 million in revenue,
384,000 in profit, and our net margins
are 15%, and our LTV to CAC is 1:1.
Okay.
So,
so things are weird there, obviously.
So, what do you want to have happen? I'm
trying to build the best railing company
in the US, and I want a 10x revenue
growth and double profit. That is an
ambitious goal. So, how do you get
customers? All right. Currently, we're
getting them through paid ads, and 81%
of our customers are coming from Google
Ads, and we spend about 21,600 a month
on Google, and we spend on Meta 4,500 a
month, and we have a couple other
sources of traffic below. So, what's the
issue? What's the problem right now?
We We spent over 300,000 in marketing
last year. Our CAC is high, and it
actually doubled from last year, and our
conversions are too low. Got it. So, you
have a conversion rate issue. So,
any other problems that you're dealing
with besides that? Another problem is
that not enough customers are repeat
buyers. It's only about 10%, and we want
to increase our LTV. So, you have a
different customer mix. So, you've got
DIY guys, and you've got designers, you
got contractors, but 70% of your
business is DIY. Um Um, what percentage
is custom versus like just normal
off-the-rack stuff? 70% are just like
handrails and like stuff that people buy
directly on our website, and then 30%
are custom orders. What percentage of
sales are coming from people buying on
the site versus the phone? Uh, the last
time I checked it's about like 10 to 20%
on on the phone.
All right.
So many ways to make money here. So, I'm
going to do this a little differently
than I normally do. Um,
I'm instead of giving you like a lot of
different things, I would like to just
give you like two or three things so
that you have a high likelihood of
actually doing it that have the highest
impact on the business. But
fundamentally, I think that we could
probably fix a lot of this with like two
things.
Okay, great.
>> All right, so I want you I want you to
go with this way and then we'll
we'll do some live breakdowns.
Let's pull up the meta ads.
Okay, so this is the
only ad that you're running right now.
All right. Are you running these or
somebody else running these? Um, I have
a a marketing agency that that works
that I work with and they're doing like
the ads, but we've definitely like
scaled down on on meta and we're only
spending like one to two thousand a
month right now. But we actually use a
post-purchase survey and
over 90% of our customers are saying
they found us on Google. Okay. Yeah. Got
it. What's good to know. Yeah, let's see
your Google real quick.
Okay.
So, CAC to LTV there doesn't make sense.
Cuz it says your LTV is lower than your
CAC, unless you're losing money, but it
doesn't sound like you're losing money.
So, something's wrong here. What I'm
what I'm seeing here though is that like
we have a clear data attribution issue.
>> Mhm. For me to say, "Hey, let's spend
more on Google or let's spend less on
Google." It's like I have no idea. Mhm.
I don't have any data. Yeah. So, we have
numbers, but they're not useful. We have
to get the attribution because you're at
a business where like you were spending
money on ads, you're making money, but
you have no idea
where it's really coming from. Besides
your post-purchase survey which says
Google. But when we look at the Google
Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. Mhm.
>> So like here's here's my red flags,
right? So number one is uh you're
showing LTV to CAC of 0.41 to 1, which
makes zero sense. Because that would
mean that every month you would just be
actively losing money. And since 80% of
your sales come from Google traffic,
then I would say 80% of your revenue you
should be losing money on, which you're
not. So there is an alternative
possibility, which is super, you know,
it is possible, which is that the agency
that's doing this for you
has no idea what they're doing, and
you're just getting a lot of referral
traffic from people who bought stuff
from you in the past, and you're
actually just
functionally blowing money out the back
end and not really getting many more
sales. Yeah. I would, like if I wanted
to get if I were if I wanted to be a
ballsy ballsier person, I would consider
looking at shutting off all the ads and
seeing how sales change. I mean, yeah,
that's the only way to find out, but I
mean But I don't want like again, I
don't want to like destroy the business.
>> we like Like last year, you know, we
spent, you know,
like 21 like thousand a month, average,
and this year we've been spending
40,000, and our and our revenue has
doubled. That data of we spent more and
we made more, Yeah. that tracks, Mhm.
but it's not being tracked.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so that's so
based on that, I'd be like, all right,
well, something's working. And when you
spend more money, you're making more.
>> Yeah. But we have no idea. And so it it
allows us to do zero optimization.
>> Yeah. And you're at the point of the
business that like you want to get from
three to 10, 10 to 10 to 100,
>> you have to know these data like the
back of your hand. Yeah, definitely. I'm
at that point where it's this data is
the most important thing right now. Like
you kind of have a blanket strategy of
like, well, more people find out about
me, more people buy, which I'm all for.
No, I mean, like I'm game for that.
>> Yeah. But now we have to be more, as you
get to colder and colder audiences,
um
we have to be more targeted with the
spend. Totally. If we were to reimagine
the business, I think that
and to be clear, I don't want to break
the business. Obviously, it's making
money. It's There's nothing wrong with
the business. Mhm. But, I would probably
optimize
for DIY
plus custom.
And the reason I'm thinking that is for
a number of things. So, number one is
you already have a strong foothold in
DIY. Number two is that they're less
price sensitive than the other buyers,
which means like even though the ticket
and when Can you pull up the customer
data real quick? So, if you look here,
right? The The average order value
is not like
So, if you had if contractors were like
$20,000, I'd be like, "All right. Well,
maybe we should look harder at that."
But, you're you're you're you're really
close in terms of average order value.
And so, there's no real benefit to going
to these highly price-sensitive people
who are clearly shopping you between a
bunch of different sources versus the
people who are like, "I think this
stuff's dope. I want to buy from them."
Mhm. Which is I'm guessing what the DIY
people are more similar to. Yeah. Right.
And so,
the basically like if we think about
this from a strategy perspective,
>> Yeah. if you sell to the contractors and
designers, you're going to be more and
more of a commodity
for them. And then, they're just going
to be shopping you up between a bunch of
other shops that do the assembly and
whatnot. Whereas,
DIY, we can drive more gross profit
because we could easily take the 873 and
probably bump it to a thousand and we'd
have the same average order, but our
gross margin would be so much higher.
>> Yeah. And that's where I think the magic
is. So, it's like even if we have the
same average order or close to it, we
could sell way more of them and the
gross margin on each might be double or
triple because the margins are thinner
in the business.
>> Yeah.
That's where I think that like the
overall like if I owned the business
tomorrow, I would probably reorganize it
so that it's just like, "This is the
home for DIY railings." And it's showing
all the cool stuff you can do for
custom. And then, people are just like
basically opting in, booking a call. And
at the end of the call, we can solicit
the sale. Yeah. Okay. And I think you
set that agenda at the very beginning,
which is like, "Hey,
um we're going to go through like
the you know, these things." So, it
would look like this.
So, it would be
you know, custom.
They click the button.
This thing goes here. They put in their,
you know, form. Yeah, one-step funnel.
Yeah, form and then we can have their
calendar.
Mhm. Right, and this can be together,
right? Cuz the calendar can take the
form. Mhm. Then after this
we have a post or a pre-call, but post
opt-in uh video sales letter. Mhm.
Yeah. And this is like, "Hey, this will
give them price ranges." Mhm.
And then on the nurture, which you'll do
via SMS here
Mhm.
is uh basically you'll ask for bant
which is budget, authority, need,
timing. Okay. And so, that's just going
to be like easy little text messages
being like, "Hey, just making sure
you're the person like, does your wife
need to be on the call? Who else needs
to be on the call to make a decision?"
Mhm. Just because and I would just be
like, "Listen, we're not a sales
company, but I'm happy to hop on the
call to uh figure out what you need so
we can get you so we can get your order
in." Yeah. And we're really framing it
as like, "You're going to be buying on
this call. So, this isn't like a long
sales process. Like, I'm just making
sure that we're no one's wasting
anyone's time." Mhm.
And then on the call
that is a
I think that is the worst phone I've
ever drawn.
I don't even really know what it is. Um
I'm going to I'm going to put an antenna
there.
And maybe we'll put a couple keys here.
I don't know if this is making it better
or not.
Um
on the call here, I can draw this one
really well.
On the call, we'll have a nice There we
go. We'll get our credit card. That one
I That one I did okay. I can draw the
money, all right. Uh and so, we'll get
the card.
Yeah.
And I think that will allow you to one,
like
I could see a world where your DIY
projects are 1,300 1,500
>> Yeah. like no problem. Mhm. And then
also, you probably have like Klarna or
Affirm or one of those financing
options.
Oh yeah, like the to Shopify has like
their own like financing Shopify.
>> Yeah. And so are you processing the
customer orders through Shopify as well?
Yeah. And so here it's like you could
say cool, do you want to pay like I
would just do AB in terms of the close
which is like hey, do you want to use
your credit card or do you want to
finance?
Same to us, same to you.
>> Yeah. Um you know, which would you
prefer?
And then that way you can just lock in
on the call. And it's like and um
and then like here you can also prep
them saying hey
um
I give a $200 discount for people who
move forward on the call and that's just
because it saves us an administrative
headache for taking more calls after
that.
>> Okay. So I tell them before they get on
the call. So it's like they know they're
going to buy cuz I just want to I don't
want you on multiple calls. I think it's
a waste of your time.
>> Mhm. And I think this process we're just
basically leaning into the people that
are the least price sensitive that you
already have the most of and they
actually just dialing in the sales
process here and this is where I think
you want to like basically let them
dream which is I'd be like hey
there's like there's 101 railings that
you can that you can put into a house.
If you have a modern house, this is
might be the type of look you're looking
for. If you have a this, this might be
what you're looking for. If you have a
this, this might and if you just have
wild ideas, let me show you four
different wild ideas.
>> Yeah. And I'm sure that there's custom
ones but the reality is that you know
that there's like three or four that
like a lot of people just think are
really sick.
>> Right. And then just show those ones in
the video. Mhm.
And you can give the ranges here. Be
like obviously it's going to depend like
on shipping and whatnot. Like I think
that if you literally just follow this
process, you would probably be somewhere
in the 50 to 60% close rate range.
And we would probably double the average
value of each customer.
So when we were talking earlier, you
said you wanted a 10x. Well, just from
hypothetical math here, we could
probably double the close rate and more
than double the gross margin. Yeah. For
customer. So that's a 4x. Okay. So
for the VSL overall, if short for video
sales letter if anybody is curious,
is that we want to have basically a
hook.
Two hooks.
Hook at the beginning. So, we go we
follow the same process for this as I do
for like a YouTube video. So, we're
going to have proof
that we can help them. We have a
promise.
And then a plan, which is like this is
how what we're going to cover in this
video. And ideally have some sort of
picture or road map that displays these
things.
That way there's a visual of like, okay,
this is what's happening. Real quick,
I'm going to show you the exact 10-stage
road map from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish.
I've now done multiple times. And so, I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as head count
increases that you need to get through.
And I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. We've done
this across software, physical products,
uh service businesses, brick and mortar,
all of this, and it works. And it's my
gift to you. It's absolutely free. And
so, the link's in the description, but
you just go acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you all free. The hook is
like, hey, have you ever wondered
uh or like have you looked at your
railing and be like, man, if I just
changed this my whole house would look
different? Um
and this is probably super ROI from a
from a home resale perspective. So, just
changing the railings in a house,
there's a recent report that came out
that showed that like railings from an
aesthetic perspective only cost a
fraction what they add in home value.
And so,
the way I think about it, railings are
basically free.
Wow. Right.
What a great What a great What a great
anchor, right?
Um now, you might be wondering like, how
do I you know, how do I think about like
buying a railing? And so, it's like
there's actually four steps,
you know, it's a buying a railing.
There's the you know, the materials,
There's the, you know, the number.
There's the the hook into the wall, the
whatever, you know, that, you know, you
know whatever those steps are, right?
And so you go for each of those. I'm
going to scroll I'll show up. There we
go.
Perfect. Yes. Yeah, and this looks
great. This is awesome. So, this one is
where I'd go like back and forth.
Oh, yeah. How to choose the right
handrail video. Yeah. I have a bunch of
Yeah, different videos. And so, at the
end of this So, we're going to go
through that whole process, right? And
uh
at the end
So, we'd put this This is still in the
intro. Yeah. Um
I'll explain pricing cuz everyone's
going to be like, "Oh my god." Cuz so
that way it'll it'll keep them cuz
they're like, "Oh, I want to know the
pricing." I'll explain pricing and kind
of like set expectations for delivery
times and things like that, right? And
so then you go through this, which is
kind of like the meat of the video.
And then we go into
price ranges
and expectations.
And I would still say
cover this here, which is like, um like
obviously these things uh they are free
in terms of the fact that they can add
value to the house uh in excess of what
they cost, but they obviously cost
money, we're made here in America, or
whatever it is.
Um so, you know, come to the call
knowing what your budget is cuz then
that way like I don't waste your time
with like making railings out of
diamonds, which we can do, by the way.
You know, you can make a joke. Um
authority, which is like, "Okay, uh if
you have your wife or husband who needs
to be on the call, um I'd recommend you
guys sit together cuz sometimes you got
one person who has the taste and another
person that who handles the money. Like
you want both of you guys on the call."
And then from a need perspective, um
they're here, so you don't have to cover
that one. Um
they're pretty high intent if they're
watching railing videos.
Uh and then it's just timing. So, it's
like, "Hey, and also I just want to know
um basically what's your timeline in
terms of uh getting it installed, and if
we were to, you know, get it get it
shipped out to you, like how fast do you
need it?"
>> Yeah. Right? And I like thinking like
how fast you need it because that way we
can try and push the urgency in the sale
Yeah. uh to get them to buy. But it
basically this is it. So, it's like we
have our we have our hook at the
beginning, we have our proof promise
plain picture, and then we set our
expectation to open loop to the end. We
have how you pick the handrailing, and
then we say, "Cool, now that you like
that, um if you're like if you're like,
'I'm not sure.'" It's like that's why we
have the call. Because listen, it's an
important decision. It's going to, you
know, change the way your house looks.
And, uh I've done this a lot of times.
And I and I tend to, you know, I can I
can shepherd you through this process
really well. Okay.
And that's it. And this video probably
you could be looking at, you know,
5 to 7 minutes. Okay. Doesn't have to be
long.
And that's it. And then we just have our
have our text um
our texts that we're sending afterwards,
which we're really just looking for
uh personal info again, and then
reaffirming these. Which is like, "Hey,
just to make sure, what did you say your
budget was? Um you know, are you going
to have your your spouse in the car or
whoever makes the decisions? And in
terms of timelines, what are you looking
for?" Okay, cool. So, I'm looking
forward to call later today. Uh
and yeah, we'll move forward at the end
of that call.
I honestly
only want to give you this Mhm. because
I only I think that's the only thing
that matters.
>> Yeah. Cuz I could like I said, I like I
could I could give you 20 more things,
Mhm. but I'll give you one more. Okay.
And I'll give you one more. This is all
this is all I'm going to do. I'll give
you one more.
Um
which is uh the long-term nurture. Yeah.
I think you should it's probably worth
building this out. How big's your email
list?
Uh like 10,000?
All right.
So, uh if you have
basically a 10,000 person list, Mhm.
you ask you had the original problem
that you're dealing with, which is that
you don't have a lot of repeat
purchases, right?
>> Yeah.
I don't think that there's like
there's like I don't want to force
continuity in this business. I don't
think that's I don't think that's really
the play.
>> Yeah. Um I think that what we can do is
try and
consistently market so that the next
time they do an expansion, we're the
first ones they look for. Mhm. But, the
only way that we can do that is just
through consistent long-term nurture.
Okay. And I think that will compound
like a snowball. Like it'll just keep
building up. And I'll bet you like you
have I mean you're doing two and a half
million your home how old is the
business?
Um it's 5 years old and like I barely
went full-time 2 years ago. Yeah. Okay.
So it's 5 years old and you have a
10,000 person list and you're doing two
and a half million dollars. Like that
list is probably a very good list. Cuz
that's a really small list relative to
the revenue. Yeah. And so um
basically I would like you to just
commit to two times per week
sending an email
to the whole list. And I just want you
to do
one is a before and after.
Mhm.
And the other
is cool Yep.
And if you want to have a third which
you can rotate like you know if this
could be the the next week you do this
one is an FAQ.
Which is what are the most common
questions that people ask that don't
buy? Yeah. So it's like these are like
bait and then this is like overcoming
the concern that you immediately have.
Because you're like oh I do want to have
you like oh but who's doing the install?
Or like how how much is shipping? How
much like just these normal random
questions that people probably you
already know the 20 questions people
ask. Just take all 20 questions and just
rotate them. Yeah.
Um throughout the year just like kind of
kind of
rotate them consistently. Yeah. You
could do that. But that's it.
Like if we just do this and then every
email I would structure
So you got our subject. That should be
an E. There we go.
Um and then underneath we're going to
have some sort of immediate reward. So
um if we can I like to do really cool
quotes.
Um
What do you think like something
immediately like that would be sweet?
You just like an image?
Well for like a new email? Yeah. For
like following this this this framework.
Like real transformation?
>> Okay cool. So we would just do probably
a picture here.
Should be like check this out. Mhm.
Because the thing is is people who are
like want to improve their home it's
kind of like porn for them. Like they're
just like they get super obsessive with
it.
>> They love it. Yeah, no, exactly. So,
it's like check this out.
We point to this thing, and then I would
just have my like CTA
uh or FAQ about this Mhm. linked here,
but the point is that we want to give
them a link and then a PS, you know, um
discount
or
joke.
Just something that's like, you know,
friendly, fun, whatever it is. Mhm. And
I think that you can basically model
this as the structure that we use in the
emails because
these people they're going if if they
love this stuff, then they're going to
open it up just to see, you know, what's
going on. And
and then that's like that's what's going
to bring people back in. Awesome. So,
it's 80% of people are like, you know,
purchasing directly on the website and
like, you know, they're just
filling out the the checkout and like
their card info and you know, proceeding
with the order and the other
20% that we're doing like custom railing
orders Yeah. is like they fill out like
a custom order form and like they put
all that info Yeah. Once they fill that
out, you know, we make sure like if they
have all the correct info, then we'll
proceed with the quote and like we'll
we'll get like an email that that they
filled it out with all their information
Yeah. and then we'll send them the quote
within like 24 hours. So, where's the
custom quote thing? Yeah, custom orders.
It's so small.
>> No, and we have it. So, where we
actually get a also good amount is that
we have it on our on our most popular
railing. Okay. Yeah, so we see it's in
the same product. Yeah, that one. Click
that one. Put it
So, it's Yeah, it's underneath.
>> Is that on all of them?
That is on the the best sellers. That's
it.
Any reason to not put it on all of them?
No, we should put them on all of them.
Dude, let's put this on all of them. All
right, so in order to do this, I'm going
to make this kind of like
up here.
all
rails
have the custom
custom flow.
And so this custom order should then
lead to here. Mhm.
Now, this little click thing is
basically A, right? Because this is one
source of getting those clicks. Can you
scroll up, Michael?
All right. One of the other things I
want is So,
can you scroll all the way to the top
again?
So, there was a banner that I saw. It
said free something and then it
disappeared. Okay, free shipping in the
USA.
Um I would have a banner across the top
that has um
uh custom
designs Mhm.
available. Okay.
And
make it sticky.
So, the the one that you have currently
disappears. Like, let's keep it sticky
across the top. Which one is the Google
or the Google Ads? Looking into this
one? Yeah, the Google shopping ads are
going to that one.
>> And that's what you're spending your
money on? Yeah, most of my money, yeah.
On on those, yeah. Okay, so it's just
going direct? Mhm, direct to the
listing, yeah.
I love these little testimonials things
at the bottom. That's really nice.
Okay.
Um
I honestly like
this is all I want you to do. I don't
think you need to do anything else.
Because if we do like if we just do
this, right?
>> Mhm.
You're probably looking at like a three
or four X. Okay.
Like I just like I don't I don't want to
overcomplicate this. Like, you have this
you have this the right customer. Like,
the reason this is so straightforward to
me is because everything is aligned.
Mhm. You have the best customer that you
have the most of that's the least price
sensitive.
>> Yeah. Um that you have that is the most
obsessed with this type of product which
lends itself towards custom anyways.
Mhm. And so it's like cool, let's And
this also from Okay, okay, does this
work for long-term strategy? Mhm. Yes,
because if if can do more custom stuff
and we know this is not that custom.
Yeah. Right? But it's enough custom that
they feel special about it.
>> Mhm. Um and I think part of the pitch is
like, "Listen, you don't have the same
railings as your your neighbor down the
street." And of course, like they would
be so horrified of that, but who gives a
But somebody else might. Yeah.
Nobody was into railings with.
But and then we add the nurturing so we
can bring customers back. That's it.
That's all we would do. In terms of
doing this in order,
um
I would set this up first.
I put these on second.
Because basically it's like we have to
have the system in place. Then we drive
traffic to it.
We already talked about this is up. This
is still the video.
Then you use this script. Mhm.
Then we add in our lead our our
long-term nurture cuz now we're getting
more leads through and we're converting
more people, but this gives us more
long-term follow-up.
And I think this you just run in
parallel. Cuz this is the stuff you're
going to do. Yeah. This is just somebody
else. You're going to write a check, and
you're going to get somebody else to do
it.
Okay.
Awesome. All right. Got it. Rock and
roll.
Perfect. Oh.
Easy peasy. So, it's been almost a year
since we filmed this episode with Luis.
My team jumped on a call to check in on
his progress, and I'm going to watch it
live. So, from the time we shot that
episode of of Cash Cows, it was April
2025, and we were currently doing 2.5
million in revenue with 384,000 in
profit. Right now, it's today, March
2026.
For the past 12 months, we've done 3.6
million with 540,000 in profit. So,
we've grown our revenue by 44%. Out of
all the changes we discussed that had
the biggest impact on profit, it was
optimizing for custom orders. That has
become
now a big way bigger part of our
business, and it's become 50% of our
business. So, once we fixed attribution,
we discovered we had campaigns that were
breaking even. So, what we did is that
we took the money out of the losers and
put it into the winners.
So, once we raised prices, our closure
rate is currently at 20% and we have
triple the amount of leads/custom orders
submitted. The advice that made the
biggest difference was optimizing for
custom orders and improving the custom
orders page and improving the sales
process when it came to taking those
custom orders. Alex, thank you from the
bottom of my heart for all your help and
wisdom. You've completely changed my
business and you've got me out of the
swamp so I commend you for that and I
know it's only up from here. So, thank
you and I wish you well. So, first off,
that was awesome. I love hearing the 44%
increase in a year. That's badass. Um
and to be clear, this is all because of
Luis actually, you know, taking action
on this. It's not because of me or some
sort of magic. Um you know, we we looked
at the the orders that were making the
most money. We put more resources
towards those ones. One of his
differentiators that he had this custom
thing that a lot of other uh people in
the space don't have that ability to do.
We doubled down on those things, served
higher customers in a higher level. Um
and obviously he reaped the profits. So,
you know, kudos to you, Luis. Appreciate
you. And yeah, so you follow the steps
and the stuff actually works. So, yeah,
go go do that. Go do what you just saw
in this video um and hopefully you reap
what Luis did and even more.